Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
has cast a charm spell on critics and
fans alike and a big part of the fun is
questing after all those d d Easter eggs
I've got a good feeling about this
spoilers ahead an important tool a
dungeon master has at their disposal
during a campaign especially if the
players are stuck or need some guidance
is creating a non-player character or
NPC that can help out special NPCs can
be especially useful if the dungeon
master needs the players to be saved
from what would otherwise be a potential
tpk or total party kill encounter where
without intervention from an NPC all of
the player's characters would end up
dead essentially zenk seems to be an NPC
who is plot relevant for one specific
section of the film and leaves when his
role is fulfilled even if it doesn't
make much sense narratively why does
zenk leave our heroes to battle the
world-ending threat on their lonesomes
when he's obviously more skilled and
capable than them the argument could be
made that due to edgin's past as a
Harper zenk felt the quest was in good
hands and he was needed elsewhere
however it's much more fun to imagine
zenk as a powerful NPC controlled by the
dungeon master of this story to move the
plot along in Dungeons and Dragons
players use their custom characters to
role play an epic adventure this can
include fighting monsters discovering
ancient relics and trying to avoid
deadly traps in fact avoiding deadly
traps is a major component of playing a
standard Dungeons and Dragons campaign
dungeon Masters will often have fun
devising complicated and convoluted ways
to navigate these various traps the
puzzles can also be overly Complicated
by ambitious or possibly even vindictive
dungeon Masters who want to make their
players sweat towards the middle of
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
zenk leads the protagonists into a
secret underground dungeon to find yet
another ancient magical Relic once they
reach a stone bridge zenk explains that
to cross the bridge the heroes will have
to do things like walking on evenly
numbered tiles then go back and forth to
retrace their steps something that would
require charts and tables to complete
successfully however all the techniques
zenk mentions are real tricks and
examples from DND modules which gives
the scene a meta textual layer of humor
to those who have played with those
kinds of dungeon Masters
I may have triggered the mechanism
so
sorry in a classic Dungeons and Dragons
game as the players explore a particular
dungeon City or Forest they will always
have a party order defining who is in
the front and the back of the line this
is because if an attack encounter occurs
it helps the dungeon master visualize
who to attack and flank initially though
Miniatures and a board help with this as
well now in a regular campaign
especially when all the players are
relatively low level it's a good idea to
keep magic users whether they're
Sorcerers or Wizards in the back of the
party so that they're safer from enemies
that's because while magic is indeed
powerful the magic users themselves
aren't very good in a fight ant can't
take much damage this is why their
classes are often called glass cannons
with this in mind it's pretty clear that
the filmmakers behind honor among
Thieves are aware of how to play the
game itself for instance at one point
after the heroes are tasked with going
into a secret passage to a dangerous
underground ruin the half elf sorcerer
Simon bluntly States I'll go lost it's a
funny line but it's also a nod to the
logic of the game namely that Simon will
needs to be protected if the party is
attacked
Simon Omar has one of the most profound
character arcs of the film starting out
as a struggling magic user and becoming
Adept enough to help save the world from
the evil red wizard sophina the surname
Omar should get Die Hard Dungeons and
Dragons fans attention it turns out that
Simon is canonically related to
elminster Omar a prominent magic user in
the Forgotten Realms campaign setting
for DMD in the film alminster is Simon's
ancestor who shows up when Simon puts on
the magical helmet and attempts to
attune with it elminster then taunts
Simon telling him that he isn't worthy
of the Omar name
The Dungeons and Dragons role-playing
game offers players a wide variety of
settings scenarios character types and
just about everything else at dungeon
master and group of Heroes could need
one of the most popular DND settings is
Forgotten Realms which features many of
the creatures locations and notable
characters that you might think of when
you picture a DND game in Forgotten
Realms balder's gate is one of the many
major cities that DMS can set their
campaign in as well as the name of the
hugely popular third-person isometric
series of adventure games of the same
name meanwhile Neverwinter is another
important location in the Forgotten
realm setting a large bustling Port City
it's also the main setting for the
critically acclaimed Neverwinter Knights
video game series which is yet another
third person isometric action game the
events of Honor among Thieves are
confirmed to be set in the city-state of
Neverwinter and the film name drops
Baldur's Gate more than a few times as
well referencing both of these settings
by name gives the film an extra level of
specificity as well as delighting the
old school d d fans in the audience
in the Dungeons and Dragons tabletop
game if a player rolls a 20 it's a
critical success and the player
automatically succeeds at their task
however if they roll a 1 it's an
automatic failure and the results are
often hilarious as one fan put it on
Twitter everyone expects DND to be Lord
of the Rings but it always turns into
Monty Python and the Holy Grail there
are specific references to Holy Grail
and Dungeons and Dragons honor among
Thieves such as Simon saying I got
better to the incredulous Red Witch it
can't help but remind a viewer of John
cleese's classic line delivery she
turned me into a newt
mute
I got better
there is also forge's gaudy balloon that
hovers over his City throughout the film
which has a very Terry gilliam-esque art
style to it as do the closing credits
the main villain of the film Dungeons
and Dragons honor among Thieves is
sophina the evil Red Witch of Fae during
a flashback set before the film we see
Sofina higher ed holga Simon and Forge
to steal an ancient artifact for her in
a secret dungeon but Sofina ends up
betraying the team by trapping Ed and
hulka in a time stop spell later it's
revealed that she was in cahoots with
Forge the whole time in the interim
sophina's magical advice helps Forge a
mass riches and political power while
she forces him to set up an event that
will get his town ready to be sacrificed
in a dark ritual for her even more evil
Master turns out that Master is none
other than zast ham that name should get
DieHard fans of d d lore excited because
in the oft mentioned forgotten realm
setting from the tabletop game Zas is
kind of a big deal in fact he's one of
the most powerful liches and
necromancers in the game's Universe
commanding a legion of Undead at his
back and call and although his plans are
thwarted by Our Heroes at the end of the
film after they collectively defeat his
servant sophina he is still out there
and could possibly return for a sequel
to terrorize the heroes once more one of
the most fun aspects of starting a
Dungeons and Dragons campaign is the
ability for players to create their
characters from scratch players can
choose to have elaborate and tragic
backstories humorous and silly histories
or even dark and mysterious pasts that
are slowly revealed throughout the game
the possibilities are practically
endless due to d d being told via pen
and paper and good old imagination it
means that players aren't limited by
much when it comes to defining their
roles that means it's very easy for
player backstories to become overly
convoluted and long-winded this is
parodied multiple times throughout honor
among themes one such instance finds Ed
and hoga being granted a hearing after
two years stuck in a high security
prison Tower Ed gives an entire spiel
about his tragic past as a Harper
leading to the death of his wife with a
fantasy creature parole officers getting
bored and annoyed in the same way other
players in a real d d game might Ed even
does the same thing to zenk later in the
film when the Paladin in tones long ago
oh getting ready for a long lore dump
until Ed angrily cuts zenk off to get a
move on
this isn't the first time that Dungeons
and Dragons has been adapted outside the
gaming table in the 80s Dungeons and
Dragons was granted its own Saturday
morning cartoon that ran on CBS for
three seasons from 1983 to 1985. the
show followed the exploits of a group of
kids who find themselves transported
into the dangerous and magical world of
Dungeons and Dragons by a wizard with a
unique name I am dungeon master your
guide in the realm of Dungeons and
Dragons
regardless of its quality it has its
fans and in 2019 there was even a car
commercial with live-action versions of
the characters in it however that wasn't
the only time these characters have been
seen in live action towards the climax
of Honor among Thieves the film's heroes
find that there are other groups of
adventurers stuck inside forge's
dangerous maze this includes the
live-action versions of the 80s cartoon
characters complete with the same
brightly saturated costumes as their
animated counterparts
critical role is an extremely popular
Dungeons and Dragons podcast and there's
a subtle Easter egg in the Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves film that
alludes to it in critical role there's a
fan favorite character named fresh cut
grass or fcg in the film after escaping
the botched Heist the insecure sorcerer
Simon is reintroduced barely making ends
meet by performing sub first level
magical spells to an annoyed audience
out in the middle of the countryside
this includes lighting his finger on
fire like a Candlestick and creating a
fresh cut grass scent from thin air the
Spell's name is just a bit too specific
to not be nodding at one of the most
popular Dungeons and Dragons related
media
2023's Dungeons and Dragons honor among
Thieves is not the first live-action
film based on Dungeons and Dragons there
was a d d film that starred Jeremy Irons
Sora Birch and Tom Baker in 2000 one
year before Lord of the Rings there
seems to be a very subtle Easter egg in
the recent Dungeons and Dragons film
that could be a reference to the Miss
begotten 2000 original early in the film
Ed and holga meet up with Forge who ends
up betraying them and trapping them in a
rug of smothering that acts like magical
quicksand this is similar to what led to
a surprisingly grisly death in the 2000
film while the rug of smothering comes
from the original game honor among
Thieves could have used any other spell
to subdue Ed and holga including the
time stop spell sophina used on them at
the beginning of the film that seems to
have been a conscious Choice by the
filmmakers to pay homage to the earlier
film
the Easter eggs in Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves aren't just
relegated to the original games or
various ancillary media surrounding it
there are also references to other films
this includes almost shot for shot
homages to the 1993 Steven Spielberg
directed dinosaur on the loose sci-fi
disaster film Jurassic Park two scenes
in particular seem to be direct riffs
from the film one occurs during a scene
where everyone is running from an angry
red dragon and Doric Falls and hangs
over a ledge as the dragon attempts to
chomp at her legs which is framed almost
exactly like the scene in Jurassic Park
where Lex dangles from an air vent as a
velociraptor collects itself to jump up
and attack her later in arguably even
more overt reference occurs during the
climax and forges maze at one point a
dwarf goes to kill a panther-like
displacer beast but unfortunately the
Beast casts an illusion of itself with
one of its magical back tendrils and the
real beast pounces on the old dwarf it's
a shot similar to the classic Jurassic
Park scene where Robert Muldoon gets
outsmarted by two Raptors in Jurassic
Park
ah
clever girl
speaking of that red dragon d d diehards
might recognize the powerfully pudgy
Beast named semberchod this character
from the d d tabletop role-playing game
is known to stock the underdark area of
grackle stew aka the city of blades
according to out of the Abyss semperchod
trades his treasure protecting services
for the life of a Pampered dragon in
lore temperature is intelligent
formidable and a different kind of force
to be reckoned with than his simpler and
cuter presentation in honor among
Thieves this was intentional the film's
co-writer and director John Francis Daly
told polygon we really leaned into the
fact that he's not like any other Dragon
you've seen before on film and what was
so cool is that it doesn't feel like
we're betraying The Source material by
having a dragon so uniquely different
because d d itself is so unique
Simon is a wobbly young sorcerer
suffering from a seriously limiting bout
of imposter syndrome in honor among
Thieves as gratifying as it is to watch
him grow more confident and firmer on
his feet over the course of the movie
there's a name that never stops scaring
him more than Kanan of arcane's seal of
Morton Kane and fame modern kanan's
unbreakable seal protects the Vault our
party needs to bust into in order to NAB
the tablet of Reawakening in fact if
there's an Arcane seal named after you
in the world of d d you're probably a
total Baddie just like Martin Kanan in
tabletop game lore Morton Kanan is a
masterful archmage responsible for
creating countless powerful spells to be
the stuff of Legend in a Legendary game
is no easy feat which makes sense
considering Gary gygax created Morton
Kanan as a player character in one of
the earliest ever d d campaigns
according to this archived q a with
gygax
in honor among Thieves the Harpers are a
secret society of good guys working as
spies to protect the Realms edgen signs
up with the Harpers for their do-good
Brigade in an attempt to lend his Bard
skills to keeping the peace edgon even
carries around their giant little book
of Oaths and pledges until he sours on
the peanuts being a good guy tends to
pay and steals some unfortunately marked
red wizard gold Ed's theft not only sets
him apart from the Harpers but It
ultimately costs him his wife his home
and almost destroys his relationship
with his daughter Ed's feelings about
his actions are complicated and more
than a little shameful throughout the
movie still zenk a far more lawful good
guy than Ed encourages him to take up
the mantle of Harper once more perhaps
zenk is inspired to keep Ed in the
Harper game because of the sentiment
shared in the Harper chant recorded in
Ed Greenwood's 1993 the code of the
Harpers we are the Harpers we are the
Lord Protectors of the Realms fools all
but the gods look down and smile Glory
Upon Us week for us watch for us and
hope in us we shall not LD if you're
someone who loves honor among Thieves
but aren't super versed in d d lore
Sophia lillis's Druid character Doric
might seem the most fantastic of the
entire ragtat gang doric's a tiefling
druid gifted with wild shape
shape-shifting ability has small horns
pointed ears and is also a proud member
of a society known as the Emerald
Enclave viewers who are up on their d d
lore however know that the emerald
Enclave are the sworn Protectors of
nature a druidic order that cares for
the green children of the Realms while
the society has its own Circles of rule
and God's not explored in honor among
Thieves the focus on protecting nature
is shared both on screen and in the
tabletop RPG world in the movie dork
looks out a window at swathes of land
destroyed by necromantic Magic and urges
her party to protect the land while
there is still something to protect just
like in real life the environmentally
focused Emerald enclaves struggle for
their concerns to be taken seriously by
selfish spellcasters and crooked
politicians alike as shown both in honor
among Thieves and the tabletop Dungeons
and Dragons Forgotten Realms campaign
one of the joys of Honor among Thieves
is that it's entertaining whether you
have an encyclopedic knowledge of d d
lore or are simply a fan of good times
and Chris Pine the movie is accessible
and enjoyable to any level of viewer but
moviegoers on the hunt for Easter eggs
won't be disappointed one such example
is the DND version of profanity uttered
by a shocked Soldier after Simon's image
spell goes sideways but what are the
nine Hells anyway the nine Hells are the
d d world's version of Hell the nine
Hells of betore boasts nine layers each
layer or plane has its own ruler and its
own flavor fire ice astral hell and bogs
there is truly a layer of hell for
everyone in the nine Hells tabletop
players can take the Highway to Hell by
playing The Dungeons and Dragons
Adventure descent into avernus
some revel's end is the blink and you'll
miss it name of the tower prison edgen
and holga escape from using the power of
Birdman Jonathan to others it is the
panopticon standing Century in Iceland
Dale carved from the Windbreak
overlooking the Sea of Ice heated by
magical continual Flames revel's end is
used to bookend the movie Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves the film
opens with the aforementioned dramatic
window leaping escape and closes with
the Crooked Forge Fitzwilliam attempting
to jump to his freedom the same way only
to crack right into a window bricked up
by an Absolution Council that is slowly
getting hip to its prisoners ways in the
DND tabletop games revel's end appears
first in the prison break Adventure ice
wind Dale Rime of the frost Maiden The
Adventure was developed by Wizards of
the Coast to support the World the Movie
Makers were developing the book came out
in 2020 while the movie came out in 2023
which makes revel's end a sort of
infinity loop Easter egg in both
properties the snowy stronghold is even
harder to escape in these sessions
considered challenging to even
experienced dungeon Masters Rime of the
frost Maiden features a dragon
terrifying ice monsters and a sperm
whale and to us at least getting to see
Chris Pine ride one of those would have
been quite the spectacle
one man's trash is another man's
treasure but an honor among Thieves one
man's treasure could also be a chest
full of razor sharp teeth and a
snake-like tongue determined to sap the
life force of anyone nearby the treasure
chest that Tolga and the Gang encounter
in forge's Arena isn't a treasure chest
at all it's an old d d villain called a
mimic the mimic First shows up in
Dungeons and dragon's lore in the
original Monster manual published by
Gary gygax in 1977 and has appeared in
Monster manuals ever since like quite a
few early d d villains mimics use
shape-shifting and Ooey gooeyness to
stun deceive and attack unsuspecting
parties in tabletop campaigns mimics get
players that get too close into a sticky
situation literally hitting or kicking a
mimic only makes it Bond more tightly to
a player which makes us happy holga
didn't try to land a punch on one in the
movie
the gelatinous cube is a classic d d
creature that's part all-consuming
monster and part Jello Jiggler these
monsters engulf unlucky players and deal
out Relentless acid damage to those
unlucky enough to get up close and
personal with the gelatinous cube the
disgusting danger of the gelatinous cube
makes its use in a key Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves Escape scene
all the more delicious Our Heroes dive
into the cube to escape forge's games
and the displacer beasts that's hot on
their tails due to doric's Wild shape
ability she's able to wiggle out of
trouble and yank the rest of the gang
out the gelatinous cube is an old d d
creature invented by d d co-creator Gary
gygax along with many other canonical
characters for the legendary greyhawk
campaign but it's had some brushes with
movie stardom before notably the
gelatinous cube plays a role in a movie
saturated with d d imagery Pixar's
onward
a gelatinous cube zenk leads our
favorite Band of ragtag Thieves into the
underdark to find the helmet of
disjunction and even saying the name of
the place seems to put a chill in zenk's
voice if a Subterranean environment
sends a shiver up the spine of a
business-like and battle-ready
semi-eternal Paladin it beyond terrifies
the rest of the Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves gang but hey a quest
wouldn't be a quest without at least one
layer Our Heroes might never Escape of
course the underdark is also a setting
for Dungeons and Dragons campaigns in
the world of the tabletop RPG it's a
massive layered network of darkened
demon-stuffed caverns and other hidey
holes that feature in many campaigns one
of the creatures they encounter in the
film and an Easter egg itself is the
intellect Devourer these hideous little
scamps boast brain-shaped bodies on
webbed feet and despite their looks are
fearsome living death Merchants the
intellect devourers show up as true
forces to reckon with in underdark
campaigns in the Dungeons and Dragons
tabletop game in honor among Thieves
zenk warns the party that the
approaching intellect devourers are more
likely to attack prey with high
intelligence well that's a little
hurtful
filmmakers Jonathan Francis Daly and
Jonathan Goldstein have stated in
multiple interviews that they were
influenced by fantasy comedy classic The
Princess Bride when writing Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves now that's a
true genre bending but we also see clear
references to Ocean's 11 and other
classic Heist films honor among Thieves
uses the visual language of crime Capers
to set up the plan of the great Vault
Heist and then launch us right into the
middle of it not going to plan there's
also a classic d d tabletop reference in
the heist portrait the party uses to
cover Simon's Heather thither staff
created portal the man portrayed in this
portrait is vola phamp Volo gadarm
recognizable to d d players for his
in-world guidebooks to the Realms of
Dungeons and Dragons Volo rates the
various Inns and locations he frequents
with a pipe system and his opinions can
be sought out in many guidebooks if
Danny ocean ever had to put a team
together to infiltrate the Forgotten
Realms we bet he'd call on Volo who knew
a hulking Beast that is part
bloodthirsty bear and part giant owl
could be so cute move over cocaine bear
there's a new cinematic bear in Town
based on a classic d d creature the owl
bear viewers new to the world of d d
will see the owl bear in Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves for what it
is a Powerful Beast of ultimate cuteness
and destruction long time tabletop RPG
players might have a bone to pick
however in the movie dork is a tiefling
druid who can transform into the owl
bear as part of her wild shape power in
the world of tabletop Dungeons and
Dragons this transformation wouldn't be
possible because the owl bear is
classified as a monstrosity and not a
beast classification has a different
impact on the games than on the screen
still some tie-in prequel novels at
least attempt to lay the groundwork for
the impossible transformation which
should come even those with extremely
lawful evil alignments foreign